everybody's seen the dirt on netflix and
congratulations for how
phenomenally successful that was
you know like but it's so hard you know
like i talk to people fans and [ __ ] all
the time right
and i i've talked to a bunch of young
people that were like
pretty much globally the meaning of a
lot of the emails communications have
been like
dude like you don't even understand like
[ __ ] i wish like i'm so bummed i wasn't
around
to to experience that [ __ ] it must have
been insane
and that's pretty much the consensus of
most people they're like
it really took them back to the way it
was which was
[ __ ] insane fourth gear
popping wheelies [ __ ] till the wheels
fall off
just running it yeah you know you've
already
[ __ ] been a part of that and just
with
you know no instagram pre [ __ ] cell
phone cameras right
we got away with [ __ ] straight
murder
you know and [ __ ] it's not like that
now you
you it's so not like that so for
to for jeff jeff did such a great job
that he was like
he told us this as um we were meeting
with different directors and jeff is
like
dude there's you know nicki and i are
meeting with different guys and goes
dudes there's only one guy that can
direct this movie and this [ __ ] me
hey i'm a [ __ ] fan and i swear to god
i promise you
i will [ __ ] i will i will make
everybody
i'm going to take everybody right back
to that [ __ ] time of exactly how it
was
jesus and and like in every detail from
the phones to the
to the settings to the wardrobe to the
um i want to bring people back to that
time
and experience what the [ __ ] that was
like you know and he [ __ ] murdered it
well what was that scene like for you
watching that for the first time when
when your character in there just did a
day in the life and it was just [ __ ]
beautiful that was so fun and so [ __ ]
real
dude yeah dude